رجعت ثانيه تهم رئيس الروسي الذي ميرفتنا
الغربه بالسيلي اضعاف بلاده وتفتيتها
وخلال اجتماع الموسعه مع عقدته العسكريين
قال فتن النبي لدى تواصل الحفاظ على
الاستعداد القتلي للثالث النووي واضاف
بوتن ان الثلاثه يعد ضامنا للحفاظ على
سياده روسيا وسلامها
وتحسين الاستعداد القتاليه النووي وهذا هو
اهم ضمان للحفاظ على سيادتنا وسلامه
اراضينا والحفاظ على التكافئ الاستراتيجي
والتوازن العام للقوه في العالم مستوى
الاسلحه الحديثه في القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه هذا العام تجاوز واحدا 91%
واعاده تجهيز افواج قوات الصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه بمظلومات متواصله
نوصل حيث قال بوتن ان العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ستتواصل الى حين
تحقيق اهدافها
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه من المعروف جيدا
ان جميع دول النيدو تقريبا الامكانيات
والقدرات العسكريه بنشاط ضد روسيا على
الرغم من ذلك فان جنودنا وضباطنا يقاتلون
من اجل روسيا بشجاعه وثبات وثقه خطوه
بخطوه لاتمام مهامهم سيتم بالطبع انجاز
هذه المهام على كل الاراضي الروسيه بما
فيها المناطق الجديده وتوفير الامن
للمواطنيننا قواتنا المسلحه وامكانيات
واسلحتنا تتزايد باستمرار كل يوم